welcome to 3abn Bible q a it's wonderful
that you are spending this time with us
my name is JD Quinn I want to be your
host let me introduce Our Guest to you
first of all is my wife Shelly really
great that you're here always fun we
just want to thank everybody at home for
sending in your questions because it
gives us an opportunity to study deeper
and it's just fun to share the word of
God Daniel Perrin JD it's good to be
here and as I think about these
questions they start rolling around in
my head and I can't stop thinking about
them and God brings things to my mind
amen amen James Rafferty via Skype in
central California Sunny Central
California
yes sir good to be here with you JD
Shelley Daniel looking forward to God's
blessings as we open up his word amen I
think that each one of us brought up the
importance of the questions and how they
get here these are your questions you're
the ones that come up with these
questions so how do we get those
questions okay there's three Avenues of
us getting the questions number one is
email
if you're going to send it by email it's
Bible QA at 3abn.tv
I'll repeat it again Bible QA at
3abn.tv if you want to text it it's
618-228-3975 once again
618-228-3975 and we have a lot of people
that send in my Instagram now if you
want to do that it's 3abn underscore
official that once again 3abn underscore
official
we love your questions continue to send
those in let's have a prayer okay father
we come to you in the name of Jesus and
we thank you for this opportunity it's
always a gift Lord whenever we can share
with others and others can share with us
so father take these questions put them
in the people's minds that are hungry
and thirsty for you father we love you
we need you in our lives continue to be
a lamp to our feet we ask this in the
name of Jesus amen amen amen let's start
with our questions and we're going to
start with Shelley okay I might mention
to you we've got 12 questions and most
of them will be three-minute questions
but they'll each have one four minute
questions
I know how much time and energy
determination it takes to answer some of
these questions some of these questions
are relatively simple and others are
very complex and so I just know
personally I take my hat off to each one
of you because I know how hard you study
for these Shelley why was Noah upset
with ham and why did he curse him in
Canaan
Genesis
verses 20-27 we find the story of
his three sons Shem japheth and ham and
also Ham's son Kanan is in the story now
the thing I love about the Bible is God
never tries to cover up any of the dark
events in the history of his Covenant
people and this story boy Noah's sin
righteous Noah his sin is laid bare what
happened upon exiting the ark he planted
a Vineyard he drank of the wine he
became drunk and he laid in his tent
fully exposed
so ham and most likely his son Kanan and
I'll tell you why in just a moment
went in and saw Noah the patriarch lying
there naked and they gawked at his
nakedness now they did something to
dishonor God's moral code of love about
honoring your mother and father they
went out and shared with Shem and
japheth what they saw so they are having
a field day with this story of what he
did
so now Shem and japheth
refused to participate in the cruel
mocking and what they did is they put a
blanket over their shoulders they walked
backwards into Noah's tent so that they
wouldn't look upon his nakedness and
they covered him with the blanket so
when Noah awoke he spoke prophetically
and we know that God guided this God
what we see is God understood
what the choices of these three men
would be ham
became his descendants were the cushites
the Egyptians and the Canaanites they
invented idols and made these pagan gods
and actually they were worshiping demons
but what happens is as Noah is speaking
prophetically he puts a curse on Canaan
Ham's son that's interesting
it tells me that either Canaan
instigated or was complicit in the event
but he strongly
it speaks strongly against them and he
prophesied that Kanan would be the
servant of Shem so Noah the curse was on
Canaan amen thank you
Daniel let's go to you this is your four
minute question can you explain number
verses 32 to 36. I'm having a hard time
with this this is coming from Greg in
Kentucky and he's looking at the blood
and killing god of the Old Testament
versus the love and forgiveness god of
the New Testament okay the story of
number 16 tells us of the one event that
happened during the the 40 Years of
wandering that is reported in in the
book of numbers and if men if evil men
were coming into the camp of God's
people with physical weapons to destroy
them we would count it as a rescue if
God destroyed those Sinners but here are
men coming in with spiritual weapons
attacking God's children claiming God's
Authority you have Korah who is Moses's
cousin and he was a levite not a priest
but a Levi to dathan in a Byram some of
the Elders of the people and they are
rejecting God's Authority and trying to
ascend to the priesthood and instead of
following God's will trying to exalt
themselves into the position of God's
Authority himself and the people are
following along with this rebellion and
if this Rebellion continues it will
literally lead to uh destruction of
God's people from within which and this
is the group of people through whom God
intends to send a savior Jesus and
through that savior save you and me well
what if God doesn't do anything to
reveal and expose sin and its
consequences well Rebellion is just
going to continue and forgiveness will
mean nothing if it's simply offered as a
matter of course to every unrepentant
Rebel the consequences of sin have to be
visible and in this story it is visible
and those consequences are decisive and
they're they're conclusive and it is
final and there's a clear statement to
the people of what is right and what is
wrong and so if you wonder about God's
righteousness here you're you're in good
company we want to see that God is
righteous listen to what Abraham says in
Genesis 18 25 he says far be it from you
to do such a thing as this to slay the
righteous with the wicked so that the
righteous should be as the wicked far be
it from you I mean listen to Abraham
saying to God you're not like that
shall not the judge of all the Earth do
right and so sometimes we we take that
verse here in numbers 16 verse 32 and
let me read it it says and the Earth
opened up its mouth and swallowed them
up with their households and all the men
with Korah and all their goods and
that's where we get troubled with their
households how could God be like that
and so I want to point you specifically
to just a couple of other statements
there and one of them is in numbers 1611
and so listen to this and talking about
the same incident says nevertheless the
children of Korah did not die all right
that's pretty conclusive but if you take
three other texts I'll point out to you
first Chronicles 12 verse 6. you can
write that down you'll go look that one
up later First Chronicles 26 verses 1
and 19 and 2nd Chronicles chapter 20
verse 19. we have in those three texts
the descendants of Korah working in the
Tabernacle working in the temple as
Gatekeepers or singers or or people you
know who are invested in the ministry of
the Tabernacle of the sanctuary and what
that lets us know is that when it says
they're households were swallowed up is
it those people who intentionally and
consciously chose to stand those of
their household who chose to stand with
them in the Rebellion against God
sin does indeed cause death and people
will die because of sin sometimes we
want to say God would not destroy
Sinners but every time we pray and ask
God saying Lord please come quickly Lord
Jesus we're asking for him to deal with
sin in a final and conclusive way God
was merciful to them he gave them time
to choose and time to repent and he's
merciful with us as well but ultimately
we have to see that sin does indeed
bring death amen amen
James and central California by Skype
your four-minute question what is the
cleansing of the sanctuary and why is
there a need for it and that's from
Maria in Ohio
good question Marie in Ohio we're going
to look at several Bible verses I'm just
going to give them to you ahead of time
Daniel 8 14 is going to be our first one
and then Hebrews 8 1 and 2 Daniel 9 23
and then Daniel 10 21 and 22 first John
1 9 and Ezekiel 21 24 and Acts 3 19-21
even though I have four minutes on this
question I wanted you to have all those
Bible verses in case we don't get to
them all so this is a comprehensive
question and it begins with the
cleansing of the sanctuary that is
mentioned in Daniel 8 14. Daniel 8 14 is
a prophecy of 2300 mornings and evenings
and then shall the sanctuary be cleansed
and this Sanctuary on the Earth was a
type of a Heavenly Sanctuary so God set
up an Earthly tabernacular Sanctuary
with priests and sacrifices as a type a
shadow of a Heavenly reality that was
going to be fulfilled in Jesus Christ
and so the cleansing of the sanctuary in
Daniel 8 14 is a prophetic timeline that
actually points to the Heavenly and not
the Earthly by the time Daniel 8 14 is
to be fulfilled we're looking at the
ministry of Christ in the Heavenly
Sanctuary this is explained by Paul in
Hebrews chapter 8 verses 1 and 2. now
Paul explains it all through the book of
Hebrews but 8 1 and 2 kind of summarizes
the whole picture
the summary is that we have a sanctuary
in heaven and a minister in that
Sanctuary who is Jesus Christ a minister
of the true Tabernacle which the Lord
pitched and not man so as we build from
that we go to Hebrews chapter 9 23.
Hebrews 9 23 tells us that there is a
record that is kept in the Earthly
sanctuary as well as in the Heavenly
sanctuary and that record of sin that is
on the curtain or the veil between the
holy and the most holy place was to be
cleansed or have a final cleansing or
blotting out which was to take place in
the day of atonement which is a type or
signifying that they have judgment and
so what we have here in Hebrews chapter
9 verse 23 is a declaration that that
Heavenly Sanctuary was to be cleansed
with blood but not with the blood of
animals with the blood of Jesus Christ
now you might ask why is there a record
in heaven of our sins well there's a
record in heaven of our sins because we
have a mediator who is seeking to
convict us of sin and to cleanse us from
all unrighteousness this work is
described in first John chapter 1 and
verse 9 if we confess our sins he's
faithful and Justified give us our sins
and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness now verse 8 and verse 10
of First John chapter 1 tell us that if
we say we haven't sinned if we say that
God has that we are not Sinners we
deceive ourselves and we make God a liar
so it's very important for us to confess
our sins so they can be forgiven and
cleansed
the cleansing of the sanctuary is the
type in Daniel 8 14 again the Earthly
sanction was a type of the final
cleansing in Daniel or 8 14 and that
cleansing has to do with Christ
forgiving us and cleansing us from all
unrighteousness
so then it says in Hebrews chapter 10
that and I'm just summarizing this that
the old Sanctuary type was not able to
actually make the the cleansing the
thoroughness of the cleansing that we
needed here are the verses we want to
look at verses 21 and 22 Hebrews chapter
10 and having a high priest over the
house of God let us draw near with a
True Heart in full Assurance of Faith
having our heart sprinkled from an evil
conscience and our bodies washed with
pure water and of course we want to end
my time is up we're going to end with
Acts 3 19 and through 21. repent you
therefore and be converted that your
sins may be blotted out when the times
of refreshing shall come from the
presence of the Lord and He Shall send
Jesus which before is preached unto you
whom the Heaven Must receive until the
times of restitution of all things which
God has spoken by the mouth of all his
holy prophets since the world begun we
are to have our clan our sins cleansed
or the sanctuary cleanse because that
sanctuary in heaven is where the work of
cleansing goes on in connection with the
cleansing of our hearts amen amen
wonderful
Shelley question number two why did God
choose to use people to spread the
gospel there must have been a million
ways that he could have done that like
through Angels writing through the
Angels or writing the messages with the
Stars so why does he use people does the
bible tell them tell us and that is Andy
in Texas
Andy that's a great question first let's
define what the gospel is because some
people don't realize the gospel is the
good news of salvation by grace
through righteousness by faith second
Corinthians 5 21 says that God made
Jesus who knew no sin to be sin for us
that we might become the righteousness
of God in him now the goal of the Gospel
is not simply to justify us from our
sins that's when the penalty of our sins
is dismissed Christ took care of that on
the cross the goal of the Gospel also is
to sanctify us to separate us a sin from
sin setting us apart for God and what
God wants to do is develop in us a
christ-like character he wants us to
become like Jesus as a matter of fact if
you are in Christ you are predestined by
God to become like Christ we find that
in Romans 8 29. so this means we're
going to develop the mind of Christ
which Paul tells us to do in Philippians
2 5 humbly depending upon God and
obeying so he wants us to have that
compassion and the concern and the love
for others when you think about this
sharing the gospel helps us develop this
sharing the gospel lets us experience
the power of God's salvation Christ's
final instructions to us well are found
in Matthew 28 18-20 where he said go
into all the world baptizing in the name
of the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit teaching them to observe all
things that I command so here's what I
will say
it's our privilege our sacred duty to
share why did God
use us Ben Franklin said we learn to
teach
and we teach to learn so
if for example you're having a problem
do you turn to someone who knows the
theory of something or someone who is
walked through and learned by experience
see Angels could share the gospel
from Theory they know about it but they
can't share it by experience as we have
writing the message in the sky oh that
would be a spectacular event but it
wouldn't have a lasting effect think
about when God delivered the Hebrews and
The Exodus part of the Red Sea they
crossed over Genesis 15 they're singing
oh he's the god of my salvation and
they're so excited three days later
later they arrived at Mara and the
waters were bitter and they are
complaining and miracles don't have a
lasting effect on people so God uses us
because he wants to change us he wants
people who are speaking from experience
and by the way I do have to say there
are areas in the world today where God
is using dreams and Visions to reach
people in closed areas and they're
reaching out to people who know by
experience
what it means to be saved by grace amen
amen
I think you meant Exodus 15. what did I
say Genesis yes it's Exodus thank you
Daniel your second question if the Lord
knows this by name and I have my name
changed because of my Christian faith
How will I know which one of my names I
should respond to if he calls and this
is John and Suriname okay I like this
question because I'm glad that God does
know our name a name is kind of like a
code when I hear my name my mind decodes
it and I I realize somebody knows who I
am but there's a lot of people who have
the name Daniel like I do and all of you
know my name but perhaps we've never met
but when someone in my family says my
name Daniel I know their voice
now hold on to that one for just a
minute because God sees through all
these external things and he's not
fooled if we change our hair or our
clothes or our appearance or our bodies
or by changing our names I know you by
name God says if Jesus voice can call
the dead to life I guarantee you that
his voice will certainly be recognized
by the righteous who are living
I think about Naomi who asked people to
call her Mara in Ruth chapter 1 verse
20. and God still know knew her I think
of jeroboam's wife who disguised herself
in first Kings chapter 14 verses 1 and 5
and God sees right through her disguise
and tells ahaija the prophet exactly who
she is when Jesus returns he's not going
to be holding a clipboard like a
substitute teacher calling out names of
people he doesn't know and it won't be
like the some government department
where they say Daniel and if I don't
respond right away they move on and say
Shelley no we can rest assured that God
knows us as people we are more than a
name more than a number listen to Psalm
147 verse 5 great is our Lord and mighty
in power his understanding is infinite
and Nahum 1 verse 7 the Lord is good and
he knows those who trust in him you
don't have to know what God would say
you have to know so him who he is the
important question is not what name God
will call out it's what will you say
when you hear what will your response be
now listen to John 10 verse 27 and
you'll remember what I told you to hold
on to a moment ago my sheep Jesus
speaking here hear my voice and I know
them and they follow me this is a
description of friendship and intimacy
if a friend calls me and he says Daniel
or Dan or Perrin or Mr parent or brother
parent or even if they just say hey
I know it's them and I know they're
talking to me because we're friends and
that's the key here the point is if you
are friends with Jesus you will know
when he calls you and God knows how to
get your attention the question is do
you know how to respond
amen very good James
what time are we supposed to stop
cooking before Sabbath starts this is
from Jimmy and Uganda
thank you Jimmy great question the
Sabbath is really a time to rest from
our weekly labors as God did from his
it's a time to enter into physical rest
spiritual rest it's a time for us to
recharge
and we get that recharged by being in
God's presence Isaiah 58 talks about
professed Christians and neo-christians
and police and the people of the real
Christians
tension the way they relate to the
Sabbath Hebrews chapter 4 also talks
about entering into God's rest God's
spiritual rest and I just want to read a
couple of verses for you here Hebrews
chapter 4 verses 9 through 11 say the
remains therefore arrest to the people
of God verse 10 for he that has entered
into his rest that is God's spiritual
rest he also has ceased from his own
works as God did from his God sees from
his works on the seventh day we are to
keep the Sabbath or cease from our works
like God did from his in order to enter
into that spiritual rest
verse 11 let us labor therefore to enter
into that rest that spiritual rest lest
any man fall after the same example of
unbelief so the Bible is encouraging us
to labor six days so that we can rest on
the seventh the Bible is identifying
unbelief as our enemy Faith slash
unbelief excuse me face that slash
belief is our friend unbelief is our
enemy and we get Faith from hearing the
word of God according to Romans 10 17.
so in Hebrews chapter 4 verse 12 the
very next verse says for the word of God
is quick and powerful and sharper than
any two-edged sword piercing even to the
Divine asunder of Soul and Spirit in the
joints in the mirror and as a discerner
of the thoughts and intents of the heart
neither is there any creature that is
not manifest in his sight for all things
are open and naked under the eyes of him
with whom we have to do as Daniel was
just sharing he knows us he knows our
names seeing then that we have a great
high priest that has passed into the
heavens Jesus Son of God let us hold
fast to our profession for we have not a
high priest which cannot be touched with
the feelings of our infirmities what was
in all points tempted like as we are yet
without sin let us therefore come boldly
under the throne of grace that we may
obtain mercy and find Grace to help in
time of need and you're probably saying
at this point what does this have to do
with what time we stop cooking on the
Sabbath
well the point is is that we need faith
and we need belief and we need heart the
sermon according to these Bible verses
we have a sinless yet sympathetic City
who can relate to us in Temptation we
need the grace we need the mercy we need
more grace we need
to be cooking not one minute longer than
necessary on the day that God has set
apart blessed and Sanctified through his
word which gives us gives us access to
Jesus we need to stop cooking as soon as
possible so that we can enter into that
Sabbath rest and get the recharge that
we need so I'm just coming from a
different angle on this to answer your
question and that is
it's not about
checking off a list and determining when
we need to stop doing our normal
everyday labors weekly labors it's about
thinking and focusing on what we need
from Jesus Christ the motivation for us
to enter into the Sabbath is to
reconnect is to plug in is to abide in
Jesus let's not let anything get in our
way let's keep our focus on trying to
get reconnected with Christ once a week
take that vacation day once a week so we
can get recharged spiritually physically
and mentally
thank you James very good
I want to take just about a minute here
and go back over our contact list
and these questions are coming from you
so if you're going to email it Bible QA
3abn.tv
Bible QA at
3abn.tv if you're going to text it
618-228-3975 once again
618-228-3975 and if you're going to send
it by Instagram
3abn underscore official that's 3abn
underscore official thank you
Shelly let's go to your third question
is keeping the Torah and the Sabbath the
same as the Seventh-day Adventist faith
and this is Johnny in Colorado
okay John interesting question let me
see if I I hope I've understood it the
Torah is the first five books of the
Bible written by Moses it's also known
as the law of Moses and Moses words are
very important because Jesus tells us in
John 5 46 and 47 if you believed Moses
words you would believe my words but if
you don't believe his writings how will
you believe my words Paul speaks about
the Old Testament and he counsels Us in
First Corinthians 10 11 saying that
everything that happened in the Old
Testament happened as examples for us
and they were for our admonition to
teach us so Moses words are important
but having said that let me say this
Seventh-Day Adventists study all of the
Bible we study all of the books of the
Old Testament because
those principles still apply today but I
wouldn't say we keep Torah and let me
explain what I'm saying portions of
Moses writings were the old Covenant
they were civil social and ceremonial
laws that God gave to Israel as a
constitution for the new nation when
they were out map at Mount Sinai now
they were a covenant and the Ten
Commandments were at the heart of that
Covenant we know it's the Covenant
because Exodus 24 7-8 Moses writes all
of these civil social and ceremonial
laws in the book of the Covenant and he
reads it before the people they say all
that he is said to do we will be
obedient Moses took the blood sprinkled
it on the people and said this is the
blood of the Covenant that the Lord has
made with you according to all these
words in the book of the Covenant later
God added more civil or more ceremonial
laws at the second giving of the law in
Moses book of Deuteronomy and it's
written in the book of the law
Deuteronomy 31 6 Moses writes this he
says take this book of the law put it on
the side of the ark that it may be there
as a witness against you so Colossians 2
17 in Hebrews 10 1 write that down
Colossians 2 17 in Hebrews 10 1 all
these ceremonial days these annual
sabbaths
that were the annual sabbaths were
different from the weekly Sabbath the
weekly Sabbath was established with
permanence belongs to God the annual
sabbaths were temporary written in this
book of the law that's on the side
pocket of the Ark and they belonged to
Israel so Moses says in Deuteronomy 31
26 he writes all of this in the
expansion of the book of the Covenant in
what is called the book of the law
Deuteronomy 31 26 take this book of the
law and put it beside the Ark of the
Covenant of the Lord your God that it
may be there as a witness against you
I've repeated myself Hebrews 8 13 when
Christ renewed the the sacrifices the
food the drink offerings were merely
Shadows of Christ's Ministry and when in
Hebrews 8 13 it says when Christ renewed
the Covenant and ratified it with his
own blood he made the old Covenant
obsolete Seventh-Day Adventists our New
Covenant Christians we teach the entire
Bible the Moses the Psalms the prophets
all the New Testament books we follow
God's ten commandments his moral code of
Love which was at the heart of the old
and at the heart of the new and by the
way all the Patriarchs of Genesis
followed these as well so God said in
Deuteronomy 10 2 take the tablets that
he wrote with his own finger he said put
it inside the ark so
your the answer to your question is
I wouldn't say if I'm understanding what
you're saying about keeping Torah that
we can keep the Torah today we learn
from it we believe in the principles of
it but this is not what I would say
keeping Torah
amen
Daniel
your third question can you please help
me understand Revelation 3 5. it seems
to me that all our names are recorded in
the Book of Life at Birth then Jesus
will eventually blot out the names of
those who don't overcome sin is that so
and this is D from New Jersey all right
d what is The Book of Life we have books
here because our memories are so
imperfect that we have to have things
written down on paper I don't think God
is recording on paper in heaven but it
lets us know that there is a perfect
record that does not fail now there are
eight specific book of life references
in the Bible and then five other at
least five other indirect references to
God writing down or blotting out names
and we're going to look at just a few of
those the first one is in Revelation
Chapter 13 Verse 8 and this one I think
specifically answers your question all
who dwell on the earth will worship Him
whose names have not been written in The
Book of Life of the lamb slain from the
foundation of the world
so in this this text there are people
whose names have not been written in the
Book of Life in other words they were
not written there at their birth it is
not an automatic condition to have your
name in The Book of Life simply uh by
being born listen to what Jesus says in
John 5 24 he says most assuredly I say
to you he who hears my word and believes
in him who sent me has everlasting life
and shall not come into judgment but has
passed from death into life so you can
pass from the condition of death and
have your name then put into the book of
life and so before this we were marked
by sin Romans 5 12 says that death
spread to all men because all sinned so
that's our condition we are you know
Marked for Death because of sin but we
can be in the Book of Life Now who is in
The Book of Life Philippians 4 verse 3
this is another reference to that phrase
and I urge you Paul writing True
Companion help these women who labored
with me in the gospel with Clement also
and the rest of my fellow workers whose
names are in the book of life so here
are people whose names were written in
the Book of Life and we see who they are
they are those who are working together
with Paul they have begun and initiated
the Christian Life the life of
responding to God responding to
Salvation now they're still deciding
their their final decisions have not
been made but they're in the book of
life because they have responded to God
now we can be removed from the book of
life just as we can be added to it and
here's the text you referenced
Revelation 13 5 he who overcomes shall
be clothed in white garments and I will
not blot his name out from the book of
life but I will confess his name before
my father and before his angels and so
to be blotted out it is to be erased or
rubbed out would be that that we have
not overcome an overcoming is not in my
power it is by faith in Jesus and what
he has done
so the Book of Life is something that
you can be added to and then you can be
removed from Revelation 20 verse 12 lets
us know that the book of life is a
minority and I saw the dead small and
great standing before God and books were
opened and another book singular was
opened which is The Book of Life and the
dead were judged according to their
works by the things that were written in
the books the dead are judged by their
works works of sinfulness and that's
many books but the Book of Life is only
one a minority and we want to be a part
of that have our names written in the
book of life and stay there may that be
true of us amen very good amen
James your third question I've heard
that God is against piercings and
tattoos is that actually the case even
if you know even if you do not let it
affect your relationship with God and
what if it's a Biblical tattoo and this
is from ronise
good question your niece uh you're
probably likely referring to Leviticus
chapter 19 verse 28 this will not make
any cuttings in your flesh for the dead
nor print any marks upon you I am the
Lord Leviticus 19 28. you know the Bible
tells us that we are bought with a price
First Corinthians 6 19 and 20 says what
know ye not that your body is the Temple
of the Holy Ghost which is in you which
you have of God you're not your own for
you are bought with a price therefore
glorify God in your body and in your
spirit which are God so our body as well
as our spirit belongs to God so we want
to ask the lord lord what do you want us
to do with this body and the Lord will
respond this is what he says in Romans
12 verse 1 I beseech ye therefore
Brethren by the mercies of God that ye
present your bodies a Living Sacrifice
wholly acceptable unto God which is your
reasonable service be not conformed to
this world but be transformed by the
renewing of your mind that you may prove
what is that good and acceptable and
perfect will of God for I say through
the grace given unto me that but to
every man verse 3 that is among you not
to think of himself more highly than you
ought to think but to think soberly
according as God has dealt to every man
a measure of faith faith comes by
hearing and hearing by the word of God
we are God's bodies we are God's persons
we've been uh bought purchased by God
we're to present our bodies and our
minds and hearts to God and God will
tell us what we should do with those now
the faith that he's given us I don't see
anywhere in the Bible where God
instructs us to get tattoos or to get
piercings I do see a text that seems to
indicate quite clearly that we ought not
to do at least the way the Heathen do
the way of the Heathen of course changes
from you know Century to Century the
world has its fads and the things that
are in or out right now tattoos have
been in for quite a while in a very big
way but the Bible says in first John 2
15-17 love not the world neither the
things that are in the world for If any
man loves the world the love of the
father is not in him for all that is in
the world of lust of the flesh the lust
of the eyes the pride of life is not of
the father but is of the world and the
world's going to pass away and the lust
thereof but he that does the will of God
abides forever so here are some
questions that you want to ask yourself
in relation to tattoos and piercings
what is the Practical purpose of a
piercing or a tattoo what has God said
about this purpose is it healthy are
there Health dangers
can it be a negative witness or a
stumbling block does it clearly identify
me as a child of God or will it cause me
to blend with the world does it draw
attention to me or to God and is it a
good use of time and resources let the
word of God guide you to answer these
questions remembering that you've been
purchased your body and your spirit your
mind have been purchased by Jesus Christ
amen yeah good answer
Shelley your fourth question
what is the Everlasting gospel is it the
final gospel that will be preached to a
Dying World
that who whoever didn't hear it may come
to Christ before the Judgment hits the
Earth
okay favorite favorite topic let me see
what I can do in three minutes get your
pen out because I'm mostly going to just
have to give you references the
Everlasting gospel is revelation 13 8.
that talks about the lamb slain before
the foundation of the earth before God
created us he had a plan to rescue us
and restore righteousness to those who
fell in sin and the plan was our Creator
God would come down to become the son of
man take on our flesh live a perfect
life die as our substitute paying our
sin penalty what manner of love is this
Hebrews 13 20 talks about it is the his
blood is the blood of the Everlasting
Covenant Second Corinthians 5 21 tells
us the goal is The Great Exchange God
put our sins on him and he credits
Christ's righteousness to us this is the
Everlasting gospel it was introduced in
Genesis 3 15 as soon as there was sin
God introduced the Everlasting gospel he
was addressing the serpent and he says
I'm going to put energy between your
seat and the seed of the woman and he
said he will bruise your head you will
bruise his heel this is introducing the
gospel by grace and then in Genesis 3 21
God opens a pathway for righteousness by
faith when he made tunics of skin and he
started the substitutionary sacrificial
System Genesis 15 6 God said the Bible
says that Abraham believed God God
counted it imputed it to him as
righteousness and it Paul says Hey in
Romans 4 23-20 but not just Abraham but
to all of us who believe in the Lord
Jesus Christ who was delivered up for
our offenses Romans 1 16 and 70 talks
about this gospel that's the power of
God
for salvation for in the righteousness
that God has revealed from Faith to
Faith first Peter 10
First Peter 1 10-12 defines the gospel
as the message that the prophets
promised and that Jesus completed in his
suffering and Glory Hebrews 4 2 says the
gospel was preached to those people of
old but it didn't do him any good
because they didn't mix the message with
faith but is it to be preached to all
you bet Revelation 14 6 is talking about
this is the beginning of the Three
Angels messages and the first Angel has
the Everlasting gospel that is to be
preached to all the world and let me
tell you if people don't understand the
Everlasting gospel they're not going to
get the importance of the warnings of
the other two angels amen amen good
Daniel your fourth question why wasn't
King David resurrected when Jesus was
with the other Saints in Matthew all
right I've got two answers for you on
this and I want to read the text with
you here in Matthew 27 verses 51 to 53
that says when Jesus died and the
earthquaked and the Rocks were split and
the graves were opened and many bodies
of the Saints who had fallen asleep were
raised and coming out of the graves
after his resurrection they went into
the holy city and appeared to many now
the Bible doesn't tell us who was or who
wasn't raised here other than saying
many bodies of the Saints so this would
be people who accepted salvation through
Jesus who had fallen asleep so they had
died and nor does it tell us how many we
don't know how many it may even be
people that are not mentioned in
scripture now it may Comfort us to know
a name because then we could say that
person made it but we are not invited to
compare our life with any other person
our faith rests simply on the Promises
of God's word and on what Jesus has done
for us so how do we know David was not
among that number we know from Peter's
sermon in Acts 2 29 where he's preaching
and he says men and Brethren let me
speak freely to you of the patriarch
David that he is both dead and buried
and his tomb is with us to this day so
we know that after David's death he
continued to stay there in the Tomb and
God said of him in tajiroboam in First
Kings 14 verse 8 says yet you have not
obeyed me you have not been as my
servant David who kept my Commandments
and who followed me with all his heart
to do only what was right in my eyes and
then Paul preaching to the Jews in
Antioch in Acts 13 Verse 22 he says this
says about David God said I have found
David the son of Jesse a man after my
own heart who will do all my will so we
naturally think well if somebody should
be worthy of Resurrection it should be
King David and it makes us think of
Moses if anyone had been worthy of the
Earthly Promised Land wouldn't it have
been Moses but he died there on Mount
Nebo at the top of Pisgah we know that
he was raised by Jesus but all saw that
Moses indeed too had the consequences of
sin and was subject to death and the
people saw that with David as well and
so this assures us here's my first
answer this assures us that there is no
hierarchy no special class even David
who is called by God a man after my own
heart he didn't get any special status
or preferred Rewards Club or or fast
lane to Heaven David is an example to us
that we all take the same path and that
path is through Jesus we do know one
name though of somebody who ascended to
heaven and that is Jesus now here's my
answer number two David's resting in the
tomb was God's way of confirming to all
of us the truth about what happens when
you die because we have a deceiving
enemy the devil who wants to to deceive
people about death and so David's tomb
resting there was evidence to them and
it's evidence to us that that nobody
there was unaware of David's tomb about
what happens when we die so we can look
forward to the resurrection amen amen
James
why did God serve why did God put humans
on Earth if this is where he cast out
Satan why did he put us in a place where
the devil is and why did he set us up to
be in a Place full of sin and this is
Sarah in Poland
great question Sarah from Poland we do
kind of get that picture but we need to
look at it closely Revelation 12 7-9 is
a symbolic summary of war and deception
and these verses say that there was war
in heaven verse 7 Revelation 12 Michael
and his angels fought against the dragon
and the dragon and fought and his angels
so right there we have a lot of
symbolism and prevailed not verse 8
neither was their place found any more
in heaven now here comes the the
Clincher and the Great Dragon was cast
out that old serpent called the devil
and Satan which deceived the whole world
he was cast out into the Earth and his
angels were cast out with him now he
can't take from this summary the idea
that God said hmm where should I put
Satan oh I think I'll put him on the
earth what we have in the context of
this summary is deception the details of
this deception are found in Reading
Genesis chapter 3 1-5 let's just go
there quickly Genesis 3 1-5 now the
serpent was more subtle than any beast
of the fear which the Lord God had made
and he said unto the woman yeah death
God said he shall not eat of every tree
of the garden and the woman said unto
the serpent we may eat of the Trees of
the garden but of the fruit of the tree
which is in the midst of the garden God
has said You shall not eat neither shall
you touch it lest you die
verse 4 and the serpent said unto the
woman you will not surely die for God
knows then the day that you eat thereof
your eyes shall be opened and you shall
be as God's knowing good and evil and uh
and and when the woman saw verse 6 that
the tree was good for food and it was
pleasant the eyes are tree to be desired
to make one why she took of the fruit
thereof she ate it and gave us to her
husband with her and he did eat so
really what happened is we chose to
believe the devil's Lies Over God's
truth God said don't eat that tree if
you hear that tree the day that you did
that tree you're going to die Genesis 2
17. we decided no we're not really sure
surely going to die that's what the
serpent said he deceived us we made the
decision and many of us are still doing
that we blame God and even Adam and Eve
but our own personal choices are why we
are where we are today and we need to
take personal responsibility the reality
is is that our situation lie eyes with
us Joshua 24 15 says if it seems evil
unto you to serve the Lord choose ye
this to whom you will serve whether the
gods of your fathers or on the other
side or or or the gods of the amorites
or in the land who's in which you dwell
but as for me and my house We Shall
Serve the Lord so God is calling us to
choose he's left us free to choose and
when we choose either the devil or God
we become the Servants of one or the
other the good news is is that God has a
plan of Salvation in spite of our bad
choices the Salvation that's found in
Jesus Christ the Lamb of God slain from
the foundation of the world
amen amen
we've got a minute before we go to our
address role it's her just just Shelly
I'm just bursting it was your question I
don't know the gentleman's name but
someone said talked about the god of
not hatred but what did he call him the
god of the stern God in the Old
Testament the god of love and the new
Malachi 3 6 the Lord says I am the Lord
I change not Hebrews 13 8 says Jesus is
the same yesterday today and forever and
I want to tell you if you look at the
Old Testament read it through the lens
of infinite love you will find out that
God was loving and patient Mercy it was
840 years before he let the curses come
upon the people when they were taken off
to Babylon from the time that they'd
left Mount Sinai amazing amen
let's take a
final address role and then we'll be
right back
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3abian Bible q a for answers from
God's word
welcome back let's go to Daniel he's got
a final thought here then it'll go to
James I just want to add to what Shelley
said with James 1 17 the Father of
Lights with whom there is no variation
or shadow of turning I like to refer to
not the Old Testament and New Testament
but the older Testament and the newer
Testament they're both Testaments of the
same thing the older Testament says look
who's coming the newer Testament says
look who's here and he was here all
along and this is why thinking of that
question Isaiah 28 21 God refers to the
destruction of Sinners as his unusual
act it's not God's will to destroy
anyone not God's will that anyone should
perish and so like you said 840 years
that's not much because God has been
giving us Time and Time and Time and
continuing time but time will run out so
God says now is your moment today is the
day of salvation come to Jesus right
here right now amen amen amen amen
message of the Bible and that message
that God wants to communicate to us and
through us to our viewers is is that God
is a god of love and he wants to cleanse
us from our sins he's given his son
Jesus Christ to die in our place as us
for us to sanctify us to purify us to
bring us out of this mess that we're in
so when it comes to standards let's stay
as far from the world as possible when
in doubt let's do without and let's keep
our focus on Jesus he will never
disappoint us he'll lead us where we
need to go heal instruct us with those
things that are going to be a blessing
to us physically spiritually and
mentally thank you James in fact thank
each one of you I mean I know that uh
we all enjoyed this also I just want to
thank each one of you that to choose to
watch us and just know how much we love
you at 3abn we respect you and how much
we just uh give our Lord and savior
praise and glory God bless
[Music]
foreign